Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Or,
Hey,
what's going on?
It's going on with you.
Spell Bernstein for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 19th,
2018 oh my God.
Two months.
They're almost over.
This year is just flying by.
It is if you live out here,
you know he live out here in Los [inaudible].
It's fucking awesome.
As opposed
she gave us the keys as opposed to live in back east where I guess it's really
fucking cold,
which is where I'm about ready to go.
Boop.
I'm about ready to go to a Becky's cause we're doing the sixth annual Patrice
O'neil comedy benefit.
All right.
Raising money and raising awareness for the greatest comedian that I ever saw
live.
Um,
the sixth annual,
it's going to be a great one.
I can't wait.
I fly out to Myra.
I'm already packed.
I got my fucking ticket,
you know,
I got a nice mid day flight.
I'm going to have a good time.
And then I'm going to,
uh,
I'm going to do a late night set of some shit at the west side comedy club,
shake a little bit of the rust off.
He'd go on and try not to embarrass myself,
um,
with the level of talent that we have going on there.
Oh,
of course.
And you know,
who has an added addition this year?
The teen idols sensation from the late great opie and Anthony Show,
Mr Joe Derosa.
Joe To Rosa.
Yeah.
Half Egyptian,
100%.
Can't,
can't wait to see them.
Um,
so anyways,
so I'm doing this,
I'm doing this podcast in the afternoon.
I hung out with my,
uh,
my family all weekend.
I had a great time except for the big fight I had with my wife.
Other than that,
it was a great time.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
and I,
I made,
uh,
I,
you know,
it was ash Wednesday the other day and I went to church for the first time in a
long time just to see the band.
They had that Dixie land band.
And I don't know why they don't have that every week.
You know what I mean?
I would go every week if they went in the back.
Wow.
What do
they do that as opposed to coming in with that haunting fucking Oregon
[inaudible].
Yeah,
right.
Shit.
You know the original,
the original support,
the troops first responders,
the original guilt trip,
the Catholic religion.
If Jesus was alive today,
can you imagine the standing ovation he would get as he walked through the
fucking airport if people weren't staring at their phones,
if they saw,
you know what I mean?
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
Uh,
so it's Ash Wednesday and I've given up argument with my wife for lent.
I'm just not going to do it.
I'm just going to experiment.
Just completely,
just,
I'm good.
Just going to fucking,
I'm just going to agree with everything.
Hey,
you want to do this horrific time eater that you'll deal?
You'll experience absolute no joy in a you absolutely.
Only if that sounds great.
You know I'm already been doing it.
It's weird and her out.
You know,
cause we,
we went to the mall today,
right?
Who the fuck goes to the mall on a Sunday?
Guess what?
This guy,
because I'm not arguing with my wife anymore.
Let's go.
Go to the mile.
Fucking absolutely.
Let's go when everybody else has the day off to go.
Right.
So we go down there.
It's a,
I mean,
it was like,
it was Christmas.
There was so many fucking people down or,
well,
the weeks leading up to Christmas,
I should say just a zillion fucking people.
We still had a good time,
right?
Don't get me wrong.
I love my wife.
I love my kid.
I loved my role as,
as,
as being a father,
but Jesus fucking Christ.
You know what I mean?
It just gets to the appointment.
There's just too many fucking people.
I started getting like claustrophobic.
So,
um,
we'd go down to this place right with fucking hanging out and everything and I'm
just looking around.
I have,
she glad I went because I haven't been to a gathering of people in a long time.
I mean,
I know people come out to my shows,
but the lights are in my eyes,
so I can't see you.
And,
uh,
I cannot fucking believe the influence of social media on just people walking
around.
It was,
it was,
it was a shit show.
I've never seen so much side boob underneath boob on top Boob,
but my wife's call,
he stopped staring all these titties.
It's just like how they're fucking out.
Everybody looked like they were trying to do,
you know,
the,
there was dressed like they were going to a photo shoot to get their fucking,
whatever your,
your,
your main picture on Instagram.
All the guys Gq it up or look alike j crew doses.
I saw this one word woman walking by and it was just like,
she looked like she was on her way to the club and she was pushing a baby and I
accidentally in front of me,
I just can't,
that's not a mom.
Moms don't look like that.
So Nias look coming.
She goes,
why not?
That's what I want to look like.
I want to,
I want to be the height mom.
What's wrong with that?
And I was just like,
well,
I gave it up for lent.
I was like,
ah,
nothing.
Nothing.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
And she goes down.
I want to hear what you're thinking.
I said,
no.
Well,
you know,
I gave up arguing with you for a lens.
So I,
you know,
she goes,
did we don't have to argue.
You could just tell me what you think.
It's right off the bat.
I'm loving this new power that I have that I'm not going to argue with her.
And then,
you know,
because I'm not arguing with her,
she's not going to know what I'm thinking.
Right?
And that's freaking her out.
And all I want to say is,
hey,
welcome to my fucking world.
I never know what you're thinking guys.
Some time right now,
it's not too late.
It's not too late.
Give up arguing with your woman full length.
And this is the,
tell him that that's what you're doing.
I'm not going to argue with you.
And they're all excited.
They think it's going to be great.
But then is you,
you're,
you're like taking away one of their major powers,
which is their ability to piss you off.
And then you spill the beans.
You know,
they get y'all fucking
man.
I'd be like,
all right,
all right.
How was it?
I was like,
cause I had another trick of my friends.
You know what?
Cause I don't fucking break my balls.
I can go.
Then she can be like,
wow,
all that shit.
Right.
So if you just sit down and you just sit in the fucking pocket,
like what was that movie?
Uh,
John Turturro did,
we played that mobster and he just did that great thing where he just was
sitting there like barely audible in front of it.
That whatever,
some fucking Senate committee,
God,
I can't answer that in the grounds it might incriminate myself.
I can't answer that on the grounds that might incriminate myself.
I answer that might incriminate yourself.
He says it like over and over again.
This gravelly fucking voice that is so fucking unbelieved right there.
They should have just given them an award.
Just him saying that line over and over again was better than 90% of the fucking
act.
And that I see.
Right.
So
anyways,
she's trying to get me to fucking say why.
Okay.
You know,
a woman shouldn't be like fucking high heels with her ass fucking jacked up in
the air and it tits hanging out,
you know,
makeup,
all done,
hair all done,
all of that shit pushed around a kid.
Now,
you know,
there really is no reason why she can't be like that.
Uh,
I just selfishly was just sitting there like I wouldn't want my mom to look like
that cause then all my friends would want to fuck my mom.
Okay.
You know,
so much of what I think makes sense until I say it out loud.
And then I realized how fucking stupid I am.
But um,
it was a,
I mean granted I was in la,
we went right to the fucking the grove here in Hollywood where it's just like,
you know,
I,
there was some of the best looking fucking fifth 40,
50 and 60 year old people I've ever seen in my life.
And then you had the young people,
Jesus Christ,
it was all star weekend.
You thought all the whores,
we're down at the staple center in the fucking hotels in the surrounding area
now.
They were over at the grove,
the regular ones.
Everybody there looked like they were trying to fucking NBA all star and none of
them work.
They would just shop it.
And I caught myself in the mirror and I was just like,
wow man.
I literally looked like I came here in a fucking time machine.
I had my old Archie bunker hat on and everybody keeps breaking my balls because
they made fun of Rogan's hat.
That one time when he said he had a little rascals haircut on had on him.
It's going to say I love that hat.
I just gave him shit because I thought he was going to come at me.
It was just a comedian thing.
Make Fun of his fucking hat.
He'll be self conscious.
He can't see it.
It's on top of his head.
It's going to fuck with them.
And then I won't have to deal with Joe Rogan unleashing his genius on my big
bald head.
Right.
That's the only reason why.
Other than that,
I liked the hat.
So,
um,
I've got a couple of those.
I've got a little pork pie hat,
you know,
I've got my own little fucking Mr. White from fucking breaking bad going on.
You Shave your head is a white dude.
I mean you got to cover it up.
Especially if you're a fucking shit.
All right.
I'm not trying to spontaneously combust.
I live in a desert out here.
I got to keep the sun off.
Um,
anyways,
I need to like paint the top of my,
you know,
paint the top of my head like,
in World War II,
while they would paint the headlights and they'd just be like a little slit
there.
I should paint the entire my whole fucking head and just have a slip right in my
eyes.
So I don't blind anybody trying to land at lax.
Um,
anyways,
but there was a lie.
And then in the middle of all of that Instagram shit show,
which,
who's kidding,
who most of this is just me dealing with the fact that things are changing and
nobody cares about my views,
which is part of becoming old.
It just said,
you're me.
I shop where you could buy pay dots.
Right?
Nobody cares.
Old Man,
you had your time,
it's fucking over.
Right.
So I'm just kind of getting to that realization that I am that guy.
I probably been that guy for 15 years,
but I'm just,
you know,
my fucking [inaudible] I dunno.
So full of myself.
I finally just realized it.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
that's something I,
I mean,
and I,
I've,
man,
I must have looked like a creep.
I must look like a creep.
I'm 49 years old.
Okay.
And I like to think I try to be a gentleman.
You know,
Jesus.
I try.
Okay.
But here's the thing,
if you're going to walk by with your fucking titties out,
I mean,
what am I supposed to do?
That's my new fucking,
uh,
you know,
when I get a text one,
I'm like some gum shoe shit and it drives me nuts and I love it.
I'm fucking winning meant I'm not arguing with her.
It's driving her nuts in a little way.
You know?
Cause she said,
well,
we don't have to argue,
but I still like debating.
So He's,
you know,
what's going on with you as always.
My wife doesn't talk like that.
That's just how I hear it my head.
Um,
so anyways,
we went over there and,
uh,
I went into the Nike store and that they actually have the balls,
they're selling tee shirts that say a quality.
And I'm thinking like,
isn't this the people that,
was it them or apple that had the sweatshop where people would jump into their
deaths?
I can't remember.
But then I looked it up and it says that Nike has made big strides,
no pun intended,
and their fucking a sweatshop environment.
Okay.
Which I mean,
I mean,
what do you,
what do you have to fuck it?
Do
Okay?
You know,
give one person a sandwich and then you get a higher rating than last quarter.
I don't know.
Top 10 ways to improve a sweatshop number one,
uh,
by a fly swatter one fly swatter for all 10,000 employees.
Uh,
number two,
what else could you do?
Um,
have a door where people can go home.
At some point.
Um,
a working bathroom.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if they're all fucking Ms. Well why did they have,
you know what I mean?
It's so fucking dumb.
When I was a kid,
they made shirts in this country and it didn't cause she a zillion dollars,
but now they just like you wasn't a,
you're juggling
because that's not because it costs so fucking much to make a shirt.
It's because they're not going to drop their profits.
So it's like,
all right,
if we can't pay this guy 30 cents an hour,
we got to pay an American fucking 10 bucks an hour,
then you're going to eat the cost and the sharp.
Okay,
cause I'm not having a smaller yacht.
You got dead fuck.
Oh by the way,
I gave to the president's campaign.
You didn't.
So what I say goes,
that's how I think.
That's how I think it works without ever having researched how much it costs to
make a shirt.
Okay.
That's how I formulate my opinions.
You know,
I look at a couple of things,
then I get paranoid and then I just start running my freckled fucking Yap.
And for whatever reason,
enough people listened to this podcast that I continue doing it twice a week.
All right.
Did you ever think about that as you sit in your cubicle,
giggling and laughing to yourself,
that you're just enabling,
you're just enabling the,
the,
the just the disease.
Yeah.
Of a sick man.
Maybe not.
No,
I think I'm sick.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck I am.
All I know was the titties were out at the fucking mall and I was walking around
looking like a skinny Archie bunker,
Archie bunker.
And I don't give a fuck.
You know,
my wife goes,
well,
don't be fucking do this.
One girl walked by,
right?
Giant ass,
giant round fucking ass.
And she was,
I think she bought Salami from the white shadow salami,
short shorts off of the white shadow.
And that's what the fuck she had on her fucking ass was out.
I was like,
me,
I look at that,
turn around and look at that.
She goes,
look at lunch turnaround.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah
guys,
you gotta stick around and raise your daughters.
Okay,
I'll tell you right.
If that woman that barely a woman wearing those fucking shorts,
if her dad stuck around for her entire Charlie childhood,
I swear to God,
I'll have a gun in my mouth.
She can be a good dad.
And your daughter's still goes to the mall with half her fucking ass hanging
out.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Maybe that's this is this part of the fucking the me too thing.
The empowerment of women.
If a woman was to walk around with all of her ass hanging out,
all that stupid shit now where it's like basically women can now do whatever the
fuck they want without consequence.
You know,
ignoring the number one fucking rule of nature,
which is you have the way you wish the world is and the way the world really is,
and you have to act accordingly.
You could walk around with your ass hanging out.
I wouldn't do it.
That's not something I would dope.
But you know,
it is your ass and if you want to have it out,
George Carlin book that he did,
he goes,
you haven't noticed 90% of women.
Okay,
whoever,
uh,
where I,
against abortion,
you wouldn't want to fuck in the first place.
Okay.
It's one of my favorite flats.
Just fucking hilarious.
You know?
That's a lot of times when you sit there and you did,
you know,
women are bitching about being catcalled some of the fucking women who's fucking
complain about that Shit.
You just looking at them going,
are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah.
Are you kidding me?
I swear to God,
you walked by a construction site,
you'll hear,
you're going to hear is the sound of people hammer and nails,
you know,
if you fucking high horse,
maybe that's because I'm not exactly a good look at person and I don't have
sympathy for people who get like a standing ovation when they walk by a fucking
job site.
Am I really supposed to feel bad for you?
Whoo.
I understand.
It's scary.
I always look,
did it like,
you know,
like whenever as a guy you watch like the beginning of Shawshank redemption and
everyone's chanting fresh fish.
That's much to be what like,
you know,
a certain,
you don't level of good looking woman feels like when she walks by a
construction site.
However,
in 2018 all women seem to be acting like they're,
yeah,
that good looking and the reality is you're not okay.
Which brings me to Olympic figure skating.
Okay.
All right.
If I hear one more fucking figure skater talking about how they had to starve
themselves because they weren't the right body type to fucking twirl around in
the fucking ice.
I mean,
am I really supposed to feel bad for you?
Okay.
You're,
you're,
you've entered a fucking beauty contest.
All right.
I swear to God,
it'd be like,
you know,
listen to some of these people complain.
It's like me bitching that I can't book a shampoo commercial or how come I can't
be the spokesperson for Coppertone tanning because you're a bald pasty freckled
no one wants to look at,
we're in business here.
We're trying to make money,
right.
So I don't,
I that they'd fucking,
uh,
what,
what the fuck is or you know,
I loved that.
I don't even know what her ne Oh no.
Tonya Harding,
I guess.
I don't know the other one's name.
Nancy Kerrigan.
I know both.
You know what I mean?
That was just all about a little fucking runt of the litter chick.
All right.
Who should have been like a power lifter or something and she decided that she
was going to figure skate.
I mean,
they have figure right in the fucking job.
You gotta be all long and fucking sinewy.
Everybody knows that.
Okay.
I don't know if I don't fucking get it and I haven't had,
you got to like fucking,
you got to like dumb it down.
There's not a weird shit going on right now or at sports illustrated use nothing
but women photographers this year is some sort of sign of strength of women.
It's just like,
well wait a minute.
So all those guys who use to hire,
did any of them get busted for doing anything wrong or did they just all get
kicked to the curb?
I'm not buying any of this either.
Now everybody has to like do something.
This is like the vagina version of like the fucking ice bucket challenge.
It's like,
why can't I just give you money?
What am I going to like dump shit over my fucking head?
What's the cause?
Is it worthy?
Is the money actually go into the victim's final?
Give it to you.
Stupid shows a strike.
I Dunno.
God,
I'm going to fucking mood.
So Friday night and me and my wife went down to go see black pants.
All right.
And,
uh,
I enjoyed the movie.
Nia loved the movie.
I enjoyed it.
Uh,
but you know,
I had a little sippy sip before I went in there and then,
uh,
I had two hits a week and it's just the weed that they make nowadays,
it's just,
you know,
I'm trying not to drink,
I don't want the calories.
Right.
So I had a couple of hits a week.
I was just,
I was like tripping.
So I'm sitting in that fucking movie,
right.
And you know,
deal,
it's a fucking superhero movie,
right?
And everybody's just like,
there's always this big drama with your family and all that shit.
And at one point I fell asleep.
Nothing that because of the movie.
It was because I was fucking flying and I fell asleep.
I don't know how long.
And uh,
all of a sudden something big and metal got thrown or crashed and it hit the
ground.
It was like,
it was like scraping and shit.
And in my brain I was flying a helicopter in my skids,
hit the fucking runway when I was trying to taxi and I thought I was going to
flip the fucking thing and do and I tell you,
I fucking jumped fucking like
woke myself up and he is looking at me like,
Jesus Christ.
It wasn't that scary.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
Nia is going to go back and she's going to go see the one where you put the
glasses on and it's this whole other level and I can't handle that shit.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't want somebody fucking hand in my face and those women with the fucking
disappears there.
I don't,
I,
you know,
it's enough for me as it's fucking unreal that people needed to jump off the
screen.
It's like,
this is an incredible enough,
I don't want to ruin the mood.
There's one fight scene,
you know,
between a couple of fans.
It's always family members is that we some shit going on.
You know what I mean?
I'm,
somebody's dad did something or somebody pissed at their sister or they didn't
realize,
you know,
Oh hey,
I didn't even know you were my cousin.
Oh Fuck,
let's join forces and go fucking try to take the mountain and get the glow and
thing and put it back in its rightful place so everybody can live in peace.
It's basically the boob blueprint of a mall.
Right.
Um,
my beef with superhero movies is like after they made,
made up like six of them.
Kind of like all the really good ideas but gone.
It's like the Dunkin contests.
There's only so many ways to fucking Dunkin and the next thing you know,
you know,
they bring it out.
You know,
some guy like staples is sitting at a desk,
right?
And somebody's got to fucking jump over him.
Use The stapler is like a fucking spring board is somebody that's just it.
At that point,
you're just like,
dude,
you're out of ideas.
Okay,
we've,
we've exhausted what human beings can do.
Let's wait till nerds continued to develop these fucking robots and let's see
what they can do,
right?
No,
you don't think so?
I Dunno.
What do you guys think of those?
So when you go to an NBA game and those people come out with a trampoline and
they're all flipping around and fucking slamming the ball and everything,
that was interesting for like two weeks.
And then I just started realizing that most of them were white and I just
started feeling bad about myself going,
Jesus Christ,
we can't even do a black people do unless we have like a fucking trampoline.
And I hate whatever form of entertainment dead is dead fucking excitement that
you're trying to pass on to you.
I'm just too much of a jaded con,
you know,
when they fucking have their eyebrows up,
and they fucking nod in as they come up.
You know,
like all of a sudden we're all in band camp or something.
Oh God,
why am I such a cunt?
Why can't I just sit and fucking enjoy things?
I try.
I don't try it.
This is just naturally who the fuck I am.
You know what I mean?
Um,
anyways,
so Saturday night I had a great weekend.
Saturday night I went to the fucking,
uh,
I went to Queens of the Stone Age at the La Forum with royal blood opening up.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking shelf.
You have to go see it.
You got to go see it.
It's been,
I have a bitter,
nothing but great things on this,
about this tour coming up.
So I was really excited and every fucking time those dead band was in town.
I've been out of town every fucking time they played the Wiltern.
I was out of town.
Where the hell did they pull?
Then they played a,
then the next album came out and I think we'll at staples,
I don't know where they were at.
Not this album,
the album before.
I forget where I wasn't in town,
so I missed that one.
And uh,
then I thought it was going to miss this one.
It didn't.
The last second,
you know,
my daughter got sick,
so,
uh,
I kind of pushed back my trip to New York and um,
I was able to go down and see the holy shit where a fucking good,
it was ridiculous.
Um,
and John Theater like this fucking red vista like kit now that just sounded
incredible and two times he took a drum solo.
I don't want to ruin the show if they do the same thing every night.
I,
they don't strike me as that kind of bad,
but like
yeah,
it just,
it was just,
it was fucking unreal.
Okay.
It was just unreal.
Near Bass player was a bad total fucking rockstar.
And then I got to see royal blood to a,
well I'm a big fan of and a mean Delray got there,
got there a little bit late but we caught like half of this sentence just to
fucking people,
Bass player and drums killing it.
Everybody going nuts.
And,
um,
I always love seeing shows it the uh,
did the,
the forum too cause I can't believe like how small that places compared to like
the staple center,
which is like gigantic.
And I probably the forum holds just as many people who's just not so many bells
and whistles in there.
And every time I go in there I just looked down with the floor,
used to be being like this is where magic or the Kareem.
That's what Mikael,
somewhere on one of these corners close line Kurt Rambis.
Um,
this is where the,
uh,
the fucking 70 sixers came in and kicked the shit out of the Lakers and 83.
Okay.
This is where that piston team beat the Lakers.
I think like so many.
I mean the Lakers were basically in the finals almost every year.
They were in the finals and 80,
(828) 038-0480 five I might be wrong about that.
86 [inaudible] 87 and 88.
Yeah.
So what does that,
that was like seven or eight.
It was like six out of eight years or seven out of eight years.
They were in the finals every fucking year.
So I just think of all the wars that I saw on that court.
And um,
and I actually saw the Lakers and the La kings play there back in the 90s.
I saw the kings when they played the penguins against Mario Lemieux.
And then I saw a young,
young,
young Kobe Bryant when he was still wearing number eight.
Del Harris was the coach and I think Dennis Rodman was on that team.
And Shaq had just got there.
Hey ladies.
Hi.
Hey.
You want to talk about that?
You know all of the Instagram people I saw at the mall,
I didn't tell you I was so frigging claustrophobic with the how many people
there that was bananas,
right?
Yeah.
But I was telling the listeners step for lent.
I gave up arguing with you all.
Is that what that's about?
It's Lens.
Why doesn't have to be linked?
But why not?
Isn't it 40 days?
40 days?
I'm not going to argue with you.
So right now if you want to,
you know,
if you want it,
you can get it.
You know any,
any of any like shit that you know that,
oops.
Any stuff?
Sorry sweetheart.
Sorry.
Hi.
My daughter got her ears pierced.
I was so against it.
Oh,
when she looks so cute.
Yeah,
she does.
I know,
but she's just [inaudible].
Why I W I was wondering why you want to see something cute once you put it on my
little pork pie hat.
This is the most adorable thing ever.
Watch this.
Oh,
you're going to start crewing and for us,
you like daddies and then a Barbara Streisand song.
Oh,
he's all,
and he's saying that too.
Then he scad sang in the end.
She keeps kissing the microphone.
Dooby dooby do.
There were no crush my head
problem with hot moms at the mall.
What's wrong with that?
I don't have a problem with it.
You're right.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
So this,
this is a no are going,
I don't know what to,
I don't know what it was.
It was fuck ass if you're not going.
I know.
I just,
I wonder,
I guess,
I guess you know,
it was what you were saying.
I was just wondering like how committed like are you,
it just seems really self-involved.
Like I like,
I mean I can't get a tablet.
Say I could get a 10.
Right.
All right.
Oh,
you almost fell.
They cue.
Yeah.
Backup here.
So like,
say like I'm a dad and I'm walking around.
I got a p 90 x body all tanned up.
I got my teeth all,
uh,
all white.
Yeah.
All White and,
but you share plugs and all that face all yanked back when we did.
Let me just say,
okay,
and I'm walking around now.
How much do you think I'm paying attention to my kids?
Less.
And I think the better you feel about yourself,
the better you are as a parent.
That was like,
that would have crushed on Oprah.
Um,
whew.
What happened to you?
Clavin for Mommy?
Cause I'm right.
You clever for mommy.
Yay.
I love how our instinct is to take the microphone.
This is,
this is definitely,
she's a ham.
Um,
cheese,
a ham.
But no,
I think that's,
it's,
it's fine.
I mean,
obviously it is,
it is putting on,
oh,
did I,
I didn't stop the recorder.
Did I?
Uh,
no,
obviously if you are choosing from like,
you know,
do your makeup or what?
He's talking to the mic.
I'm watching her.
Okay,
good.
Hi.
Um,
if you were like,
you know,
I would play with my child for five more minutes,
but I have to do my,
I don't know,
I don't like to judge people,
but I think it's cool that you can like have yourself together and look amazing
and still go out with the kid and like do your thing.
I think that's great.
Do you realize that if I didn't judge people,
we'd both be homeless?
It's all I do.
Um,
I get about,
I told him how I,
I passed out in a black panther and I thought it was in a helicopter crash.
You did pass out.
But to be fair,
you started booze and before we went and I had one glass,
it was a big glass.
It's a big boy glass.
It's a goal.
Would you will
have a little shippy before the movie?
Oh boy.
Yeah.
Anyway,
you had a,
you had a big last and then you know,
we did the other thing.
So I'll tell you right now,
I've worked a lot of that thing.
I were pretty faded so I wasn't even buzzed off of that.
You were the walking down the street,
you were psycho weed.
I always forget to just take a hit and a half.
I don't have cycle.
We,
yeah,
I am.
And I went in there and all of a sudden digits my brother and I was just
tripping.
Yeah.
And then I passed out in that,
that spaceship or something crashed.
Did you feel when I
do bad,
you passed out?
Cause it was a really good movie.
I thought it was a growing.
When I saw,
I saw,
I really enjoyed the ACA was great.
I liked the envelope brother.
I'm going to see it.
And evil brother in the evil white dude were great.
So I like the evil brother too.
Actually.
I don't feel like,
I don't want to spoil it for those who,
yeah,
let's stop talking about it.
All right.
I guess it only just came out,
but um,
I'm going to go see it again tomorrow and four dx.
Have you ever heard of this?
What are they going to do?
They're going to get,
it's like a universal ride where the seats move and maybe they miss it with a
garden hose.
I don't really feel like it's necessary for all that.
So I'm glad we saw the record.
Look at this chair.
I'm just,
I'm glad we saw the regular version cause so I could really concentrate on the
story.
Okay,
so what are they gonna do if they're gonna like throw stuff at you?
I,
I have no idea.
We'll see.
It's like Gallagher if meat's going to the movies.
Yeah.
God,
I hope not.
That's Calgary's got great material though and nobody understood that.
I'm telling you that that sled dramatic was ironic.
He was making fun of advertising and then everybody took it at face value.
Like,
okay,
oh I hope he change the big thing.
A cottage cheese and I get hit in the face with it.
Yeah.
They didn't get it.
What's that?
What are you giving me anyways?
Yeah.
Let me do it.
I got to read a little bit of the,
uh,
the advertising,
right.
Well,
we came in to say,
oh,
just say good night,
sleep tight then plasms rooms.
Do you,
it was a wish and a prayer we saw.
Is that what's you every day I was in the Lawrence Welk show will come true.
A now to lead.
It's all white.
A guy.
I am the other,
you married an Ios or a Var?
Vito Zane.
Good night.
And then they'd come in with,
is that the end of the Lawrence Welk show?
Is he the guy,
the front arm?
That was basically our soul train.
Black people stole soul train from that was the results right now.
Bobby and Susie or nap time.
Hey.
Oh good.
It was boring.
Is that the um,
sorry.
Uh,
is that the guy,
the Fred Armisen would make fun of like,
we'll do an invitation of on um,
on SNL?
Yeah.
And then like Kristen Wiig would come out as the like weird woman with like the
little hands might,
no,
I don't,
there was nobody a little hands on Lawrence Welk.
Oh No,
I know,
but I'm just saying,
I dunno.
I don't know what Lawrence Welk is.
That definitely sounds like some white shit.
Cool.
Whoa,
whoa.
You're all excited.
You're walking around.
Okay.
Yeah.
What do you,
what's so funny?
She just cracks up to herself like all day long.
I know.
I want to be like,
what do you think?
What is out of place in the universe that it just struck you as funny?
I remember when she was like super,
super little.
She just be crawling along and then she just stopped and just go Kiki,
Kiki,
Kiki Blake.
She just has her own little secret thing going on.
Got It.
She has an imagination.
All right,
let me,
uh,
I got to read some,
wait,
wait.
No,
no,
no.
That was going to touch the mic,
so,
okay.
Hey,
beautiful.
Can you say bye bye.
I'll see you.
I won't see in the markets.
I know.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Thank you honey.
Say Bye bye.
Bye Bye.
And a kiss her.
All the listeners.
All right,
bye.
Bye.
Oh,
I have to sing to me on the song and she can't be in here for this.
Okay.
Hi.
Daddy is a an idiot and he makes money.
Okay,
honey.
Shame.
Filthy fixed.
That's go.
All right on.
All right.
See you later.
Bye Bye.
Hello.
All right,
come on.
These people are getting bored.
Me,
they're getting born.
Ei.
Ei,
Lsu.
A new thing.
The scowl.
Somebody tells you not to do something.
You start looking at me like what kind of authority do you have?
It looks at you like
you look.
I know.
The only time anybody says my daughter looks like me is when she's in a bad
mood.
She gives somebody a look.
Oh,
she does look like bill.
Yeah.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh,
okay.
Here we go.
Oh,
look who it is.
Everybody.
Me On days.
Oh,
but oh,
don't do me.
Andy's me undies.
Mom is dressing like a horrible dude,
dude.
Dude,
me undies,
me undies.
It did sir.
Floor.
So as she goes to a doctor,
get some perked up,
take some fast fed sticks in an ellipse.
Now she's dating somebody.
Two grades below me.
Mandy's everybody,
sorry.
You want to look good and your underwear and be comfortable,
but that perfect balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me undies.com and find the best pair of underwear in the world.
Talk about why me undies is the best underwear you will ever own.
Feel free to improvise.
Well,
I have a pair and I have to tell you,
uh,
they feel nice on my balls.
It's weird.
It's like,
am I wearing underwear?
Oh,
yet,
yes,
I am a,
it's like the wonder woman jet on your balls,
except it's underwear.
Me undies will be the most comfortable pair of underwear you will ever own.
Made from sustainably sourced naturally soft fabric,
fucking computer screen.
Come on.
Uh,
that is three times softer than cotton.
Ultimate feel good undies for when you want to feel naked.
Not Be naked.
100% satisfaction guarantee.
The guarantee you will love your undies or your money back.
Speaking of underwear,
the worst fucking underwear commercial is that one where they have like the
construction worker.
They're like,
no pinch,
no,
no stench.
It's like Jesus Christ,
this guy with his bulldozer nuts.
I don't need to hear about that right now.
Me undies has an exclusive offer just for my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and free shipping and the Andes is so shoe,
uh,
you will love their underwear.
They even offer a hundred percent satisfaction.
Guarantee.
Your order,
you order a pair,
you order a pair motherfucker and you don't love.
If you don't love your first pair,
you get a full refund.
This is a no brainer to try 20% off free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
What in God's name are you waiting for to get you 20% off free shipping in
there,
100% satisfaction guarantee and you get the best and softest underwear you will
ever own.
Go to me undies,
dog comp.
Slash.
Bird that's meundies.com/.
Bird this is a limited time offer,
so what in the fuck are you waiting for?
Start wearing your best underwear if your life.
It changed my life evidently according to the copy.
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to me undies.com/ [inaudible] right now.
You know,
I shouldn't have said those things about figure skaters.
um,
I know I'm just sick of listening to people fucking bitching,
you know,
about body image and all of that shit.
The it,
can we at least agree that there are people better looking than other people?
Um,
I dunno.
Maybe I'm a realist.
I know I'm a,
I'm know I'm riding the bench and the look department,
I'm like that hack they put in at the end of an NBA game and fucking people go
nuts.
If I just get a fucking bucket,
I hit a foul shot,
you know,
cause the home team's by 30 a dollar shave club.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club delivers to you everything you need to look,
smell it,
feel your best shampoo,
body wash,
toothpaste,
and of course the best razors that you will ever use.
Get an amazing high quality shave every morning from dollar shave club's
executive race.
But the true hero of any morning routine is their Dr Carver's shave butter,
easy shave Pato.
Some of those thickies you want to figure skate.
I think they put it between your thighs when they get out there and they end up
being too powerful for the old white judges.
That's all wanna.
That's not what beauty looks like.
It looks like me.
What?
It looks like beef.
Uh,
it helps the razor gently glide across your skin.
you have to experience it or another must have experience is how dollar shave
club delivers everything to you.
Speaking of which,
I really liked fucking Mary Lou Retton back in the day.
I thought she had a nice body.
My mother was telling me,
I think she's a little too,
she's a little too powerful.
Okay.
Uh,
that means no more trips to the store.
Wandering,
wandering the aisles,
hunting for razors,
shampoo,
toothpaste.
Then having to play at being a cashier,
scanning it,
bag in your own stuff.
Oh,
God knows.
I fucking hate that for a mind blowing experience.
Join Dollar Shave Club today.
All right.
Take it down.
Dollar Shave club or rates.
Fucking convenient.
It's not going to blow your mind.
I can't believe I ordered so many key to my house.
It's like everything on the Internet.
Um,
whatever they're saying,
there's going to be mind blowing.
They must have some fucking ass shaver or something that they throw in.
It's a free thing.
And for just $5,
with free shipping,
you'll get the six bladed executive razor plus trial sizes of shave butter,
body cleanser and one light.
One white.
Sure.
Then keep the blades coming for a few bucks a month.
Get yours@dollarshaveclub.com [inaudible] dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible]
that's dollar shave club.com/burr.
You know what I saw today?
That was fucking not two days ago.
It was fucking hilarious.
Um,
this woman in like a,
either a washy fee at 500 or a fucking,
uh,
one of those cars,
those British cars,
a mini Cooper smashed into a pole and like literally knocked her front fucking
tire off and there was no other person involved in the accident.
And uh,
it reminded me of that old game that I used to play called older Asian a
stamps.com because there was nobody else around this person.
They must have been on the phone.
stamps.com is the easiest way to to across
don't to access.
I got to get class@stamps.com is the easiest way to access all these amazing
services of the post office.
Print postage for any male class right from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage time never underpay or Overbay.
Again,
I'm gonna use my soothing voice in this stamps.com saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package you suggest my computer and printer and the mailman comes and picks
it up.
It's actually a woman,
the male woman.
Can we say male person?
Are you ashamed of being called a woman?
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the post office right to your
fingertips.
Buy and print official US postage for any lab,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and they'll send you a digital scale
automatically.
It automatically calculates exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide
the best glass of mail based on your needs.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my posters.
If I'm going to whore myself out at the end of my fucking shows,
uh,
I'm a moron.
If I can figure out how to do it,
then so can you,
and right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter.
Bruh.
You know what?
Now I feel bad that I made fun of figure skaters because I remember seeing this
African American woman and she was out there killing it,
doing back flips and shit,
and they couldn't deal with how fucking strong she was.
And they're like,
that's not what a woman looks like.
So I felt bad for her.
I guess I just don't feel bad for Tonya Harding.
You know what I mean?
And I don't buy that.
She didn't know it.
You know what I mean?
If somebody is going to go out of their way,
one of those guys was going to go out of their way to smash somebody's knee.
So you would win.
They're going to let you know because they're obviously trying to fuck you.
Right.
That would have been my argument if I was a prosecution.
What kind of guy goes out and breaks the knee of another woman for another woman
without telling her.
I mean he's a guy.
All right.
He's a heterosexual guy.
I mean it's somewhere there has to be a blow job at the end of the rainbow or
reason not getting out of bed in the morning.
No further questions.
All right.
Gun Control.
Ah,
Jay Jay's.
I stepped into it with this one.
I'm trying to see if we can just,
somebody can just explain to me.
Uh,
I'm open minded about it cause I don't know shit about guns.
Why you need an Ar 15 to fucking defend your house?
Do people break into your house in packs of 40 that's all I'm asking.
Or is it,
is it better in a tight spot?
You know,
my big thing with any gun is how loud is it?
how loud is it?
Like,
cause I don't want,
if my ears I've already fucked up.
You know what I mean?
I can't even use a cap gun.
Um,
I think I'm going to go with just like bear Mace,
you know.
All right.
Gun Control.
I love it.
He's spraying mace and then the guys still coming at you and then you got to run
through the,
that you just fucking spray now you're both fucking can't see shit like gun
control.
Here we go.
Billy.
Red Balls of fire.
A huge fan and love your work.
Much respect and enjoy your success.
Thank you.
I'm a lifetime NRA member and I believe in the second amendment out.
Jesus fucking Christ.
We get it.
I'm a Metallica fan and I like to rock.
Well,
can we not be so fucking redundant?
Jesus fucking Christ Kate.
But,
but being that it is an amendment,
we could change it to correct it for today's of everyday events and happenings.
All right.
These school shootings could be narrowed down if we would do a way with assault
rifles.
Now.
I know there's a lot of gun people right now going,
this isn't a real gun person.
This is somebody,
some liberal fuck and he hippie.
He glued a bear to his face.
He rented a bass boat and then he sanded this and font to act like he speaks for
me.
He does not.
All right.
These school shootings could be narrowed down if we would do away with assault
rifles.
Yes,
there would still be violence in schools,
but a 20 or 12 gauge shotgun is a lot harder to hide than a nine millimeter
glock.
I also have a good idea right now you can go to a,
to a bass pro shop,
Walmart and half a dozen other stores to buy ammo.
Since here in New York we have to register our guns annually.
We could also make a state run ammo only store.
State run.
Okay.
A state run ammo only store,
kind of like Canada's beer liquor store by your guns,
wherever.
Register them with the state annually and by your ammo through the state.
That way any large or odd ammo purchases would be tracked along with your
background check.
It's really the best idea I can come up with.
As always.
Hello to the lovely Nia and thank you for putting up with his ginger ass and
bill.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's hilarious.
Um,
all right,
so there's some ideas.
There's some ideas.
Uh,
all right,
it's okay.
Mass shooting proposals.
Hey there,
willingness to bills.
Um,
here's my proposal to reduce mass shootings,
get communities to come together.
It seems like a simple idea,
but here's my logic.
How many people interact with or even know their neighbors?
My parents divorced when I was four years old and during my alternating custody
I noticed a few major differences in their individual happiness.
And one of the,
my minor Dietz and one of the minor details period was my mother always made it
a point to say hi to her neighbors and hand out cards on the holidays where my
father avoided neighbors at all costs.
It sounds like me.
And also was talking shit and saying negative things also sounds like me as an
adult,
I don't dole out kiss,
but I do make it a point to say hi and shoot the shit with all my neighbors.
I believe of communities regularly interacted or even held monthly or seasonal
events like block parties.
They could build a trust and dependence for each other and if you notice a
neighbor kid acting shady,
it could be noted in the kid could get the help they needed without feeling
disconnected in abandoned.
As I said,
it's a simple solution.
As much as I'm a simple man,
may one or more gods or fewer,
bless you and your family and go fuck yourself.
Ps,
I was raised around people of the LDS faith,
Mormons and I see these interactions between them regularly.
Anecdotal evidence or not.
It's an idea.
All right.
Okay.
Uh,
gun response.
I just want to hear what people have to say.
I usually comment on the shit.
I just haven't really,
I don't need it cause I don't know shit about this.
I guess that's what it is.
No one has been able to tell me why you need,
yeah,
it's just a gun owner would be fucking honest.
When it comes to assault rifles,
why do you want to know?
Why?
What do you need an assault rifle for?
And it's like,
I don't need one.
It's just fucking awesome to just go down to the gun range to go.
Yeah,
I did tech,
tech,
Tech Tech.
Right.
And just fucking have a good time with it.
It's like,
who needs a fucking Ferrari?
Nobody.
Right.
Nobody needs a fucking Ferrari.
All you need is a god.
You'd have fucking a Prius to get to work,
but who doesn't want a Ferrari?
They're awesome,
but in the wrong hands.
All right,
gun response.
Billy band bullets.
I never said to Ben Bullets.
Love the podcast like that.
You're a very humble guy.
I'm completely full of myself,
sir.
Doing stand up at night is not enough.
I have to still have a microphone in my hands,
even in my house.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
I love,
I grew up in South Alabama and I'm just getting out of the Marine Corp offers a
training.
Stereotypically,
I'm a conservative with a moderate knowledge of guns.
So to answer your question,
the second amendment is to protect yourself and others from tyranny.
Exactly.
That's why the what that other guy saying that only the state should give out
the bullets that dad I didn't like because I don't trust,
I'm not like,
I don't touch the Gobi me man.
Just the way that it's set up right now.
MMM.
It's just,
I dunno,
it's just,
it's not a,
it's not a good thing if only the people who are in control have the weapons.
MMM.
Yeah.
I,
I just don't think that,
you know,
we already see what it's like if the,
if only the people in control own basically all the major news sources.
You see what it's done to this fucking country.
If you fucking paying attention,
um,
how few things you can talk about,
which is why everybody is sitting around talking and calling everybody heroes
and this and that and fucking this person's brave and this person's a bad person
and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
well,
they just take turns solid until like,
we all went back to school.
Like we're sitting on a fucking playground and we have major goddamn problems
that nobody's talking about,
you know?
Um,
I'm off my high horse.
Okay.
Yeah.
A stereotypically I'm considering,
okay.
Seems farfetched.
But look up deaths from government tyranny in the last century.
Semiautomatic rifles like the armalite 15,
I guess that's the Ar 15 Aka the ar 15.
Yep.
Are the minimum needed firepower for a guerrilla militia to fight organized
militaries.
Ar 15 is not a military grade weapon or assault rifle by official standards.
The main reason being effective firing range,
uh,
pistols are almost as effective at close range.
So a ban on ars won't do much if anything for most of these horrible events.
And we'll eliminate purpose of second amendment.
Well,
I mean,
when our,
wait a minute,
dude,
wait a minute.
The how much,
how fast you can shoot and how many people you can fucking hit.
I mean,
if you walk into a crowded area,
how good his shot they have to be.
Um,
I just wish one of these gun people would just be able to say,
I don't want him to ban an ar 15 cause I'm not fucking crazy.
And I enjoy shooting the fucking woods up with this thing.
It's fun.
Um,
I just,
there has to be a way,
it just can't be that fucking easy
for a fucking lunatic to get their hands on it.
Because the bottom line is,
there's nothing wrong with guns as long as you're not a fucking lunatic.
But the problem is,
is it's obviously too easy as a lunatic to get one.
Does that make sense to gun people?
Noncom there?
I mean,
guns are fucking great.
Like I can guarantee I have a baseball bat under my bed and I can guaran fucking
tee.
If anybody came in my house,
what's the one fucking thing I would wish that I had?
I wish I had a fucking gun.
You know,
my,
my wife doesn't like him.
She's afraid of him,
which I get now we got a kid,
so I'm not,
you know,
not going to fucking do that.
MMM.
You know,
I,
you know,
and I also don't think,
if you get a turn,
everybody turned in their fucking guns.
The only people that can do that are honest people.
What a bad people.
They'd be like,
well,
I guess we've got to turn it up fucking guns.
MMM.
I just,
it has to be some sort of,
uh,
okay.
I don't know how to fuck.
Do you figure out who's fucking nuts or not?
That's the problem.
Anyways,
subsequent,
subsequently,
almost all gun deaths are from pistols.
Solution increase,
increase the age of legal purchase to 21 for anything except pump action,
shotguns and black powder rifles,
pistols.
You already have to be 21.
Okay.
Also armed security at schools,
not a cure.
Uh,
all but better than nothing.
Yeah.
Why don't they have armed people in schools?
You know,
I wouldn't have a problem with that.
By the way,
founding fathers had a concept of machine guns and certainly of semiautomatic.
They weren't using micro aggressions.
Aggressions,
you,
Cali Lib.
What do you mean they had a concept?
I have a concept of a flying fucking car.
Do I know what that's gonna do to the world?
Yeah.
Um,
Hope Paul,
that clarifies a point of view without being too in depth.
Thanks for question.
You're questioning your stance on the issue.
Um,
what was their,
what was their concept and how do you know they had a concept?
Did new evidence show that they had this,
what did they have beyond what that will,
that first one that came up with what it had to be like pushed by nine people
and then he had your little crank and get,
get,
dig,
dig.
You know.
Then the guy who came up with the machine gun,
he wanted to do that to lower depths are heard some other bullshit I heard like
he was just like,
well this thing can shoot as much as an entire platoon so you won't have to have
a platoon.
Then you can have less people in the army because this person's going to be
shooting just as much.
And then all the Sickos at the top are like dead.
We will have a platoon,
a platoon with all machine guns.
And it just keeps a grass.
That's war.
That's a completely different fucking thing.
Um,
I'm going to go out on a limb and I don't think the founding fathers had a
concept of what the fuck of,
of the,
the level of population.
I mean,
there's just so much was fucking different back then that they had the concept
of an ar 15 and a fucking food court in the 17 hundreds.
I,
you know,
maybe they did.
I mean,
they weren't,
they were pretty,
you know,
I dunno.
Flying Kites with keys on him.
I'm a guest that makes you a smart guy.
I Dunno.
All right.
Um,
all right.
Gun.
Yeah,
but I liked this because nobody's telling me to go fuck myself or anything like
that.
You notice people when you just sort of ask what you'd thinking,
people will then act civilized and as opposed to all you idiots.
Don't fucking,
I shouldn't say it,
folks.
You,
all of you individuals who all have a right to your opinion,
the way you guys address each other on social media is,
you know,
I don't know.
It's just the quickest way to have an a vein.
Pop it out of your forehead.
All right.
Gun,
ESPN,
Billy Muskett Mug.
I don't know what that means is funny.
You write about the media turning the shootings into ESPN for killers.
The number they keep throwing around is 18 this year.
They're counting suicide's a time where a gun went off in a car.
Another was a kid who pulled the police officer's triggering class.
Here's an article about it.
Uh,
no,
I was saying that when the mass shootings,
the way,
the way they say like this is the deadliest,
this is the third deadliest,
this is the most blah,
blah,
blah.
And then they splattered a person's face all over the fucking news.
And I just don't think that they should show the person they should die
anonymously.
Uh,
and that's it.
I wouldn't even like not even cover the fucking story.
Yeah.
I mean,
the people that need to know,
no people that lost people or add people affected by it.
I okay.
And I dunno to go beyond that.
Then what am I sitting there watching it for a second?
Watch people cry and see people with the worst day of their fucking life.
Why do I need to know that,
that that happened?
Okay.
Law enforcement is going to get the person,
they're going to fucking prosecute him and all of that type of shit.
Why do I need to know that that is going on?
I can't defend myself against it.
I'm not going to go do it.
Right.
However,
if you some Sicko and you're watching that shit,
you know,
I think Sickos watched those stories the way you know,
I used to watch rock bands and it made me want to play drums.
Um,
all right.
Non Americans view on guns.
Uh,
I'm of the opinion that the occasional mass killing in the u s is the price you
pay for your government not turning in and do Hitler's Germany or Stalin's
Russia.
It might be the only thing keeping your government from going full retard.
My country,
New Zealand,
the New Zealand might be protected in turn by the stability of the USA.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm deck guy must be way smarter than I am.
I don't know what the fuck any of that means.
I'm of the opinion that the casual mass killings is the EU USA in the USA is the
price you pay for government not turning into Hitler's Jeremy of Stalin's
Russia.
So because we're,
we're allowed to be freer than them,
the price we pay.
Is that,
is that what you're saying?
And it might be the only thing keeping your government from going full retard.
Uh,
which if you look at the economics of the war that we're fighting,
it has because I don't know how we keep doing this
or why we're throwing this much money.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
I dunno.
You know,
why the fuck we're doing it.
Everybody does.
Alright.
Lifting weights.
Hey Bill,
I'm a longtime fan of the podcast.
Just wanted to respond to your comment about not lifting weights.
While it's a great that you recognize the negatives of lifting weights as a
primary routine,
I would not count out curling a few dumbbells every now and then.
They spent a lot of research about the cardiovascular benefits to basic
weightlifting.
I suggest low weight,
high reps at least once a week.
Thank you.
I 100% agree with that.
All right.
But the problem is is I came up in the 80s so it's all about doing what are you
benching and how I got hurt was a one time in my life I was able to put up to 25
which is two 45 is on both sides.
I finally felt like a big boy in the gym.
So like an asshole whenever I first hurt myself,
which will,
I think I was a 48 you know,
I already,
I a year ago this past October,
so that would be 20 in October,
2016 a fucking Jim put in.
I was all excited and I fucking,
the first day fucked up my shoulder and I had never done it before so I just
tried to push through it and I kept lifting and now it's just completely,
it's completely fucked up.
And every time,
I think I'm getting towards the end of it.
Like I have,
you know,
I now have this strength back where I can like,
pick up shit and everything,
but my mobility is really fucked up.
So,
uh,
I haven't been to the physical therapy in a minute.
I gotta get back to that,
but I just spend it,
got a little busy here.
But um,
I agree with that 100% use it or lose it.
But you know,
don't try to fucking lift what you lifted when you were 20.
All right.
My wife is nuts.
Hey guys,
keep us sending shit in about the gun control stuff because I think it's,
it's really interesting as far as like a,
you know,
to just hear people's opinions and where they're from and why they view stuff
the way they do without fucking screaming at each other.
And hopefully,
you know,
I dunno,
I just can somebody way in how,
okay,
whether you're pro gun or not pro gun.
All right.
How,
uh,
you know,
cause psychos do a lot of shit.
PSYCHOS getting cars and they drive into fucking people.
And all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
They don't try to fucking make,
take cars away from everybody.
I know that's overly simplifying it,
but,
um,
you know,
I think it's,
I don't know.
I just don't,
I don't even know.
I'm not into guns.
I just don't look at them like they're these,
these fucking like they were alive and they have the devil in him.
Um,
I do find them scary.
You know,
I have gone to gun ranges and I shoot and it's fun.
Once she kind of,
it's like anything first started flying a helicopter,
I was like,
is this thing going to chop my fucking head off?
And then once you get into the physics and how the whole thing works,
it becomes absolutely fascinating.
So,
uh,
you know,
I think those people go skeet shooting.
I think that's the shit.
And I think people that hunt this is fucking amazing,
that they know how to do that and build a fire and survive outside.
It's probably an important thing that you need to know how to do.
I respect all of that shit.
It's just a how to,
so in those people should be allowed to continue doing that.
I just wished there was a fucking way that you could figure out when somebody
came up to be like,
may maybe that's dead.
Something good for Alexa is everybody bugs their house.
Right?
Maybe one of those fucking lunatics will be muttering to themselves,
you know,
God knows I have a little camera in there.
They'll see the person fucking bringing all this fucking ammo.
Um,
I dunno.
Even then,
it's just even if he'd be limited,
the amount of ammunition,
the amount of fucking damage that you can do just by,
I would think just buying a box of bullets.
It's fucking nuts.
I didn't like talking about it.
It's so fucking creepy.
All right.
Wife is not,
but I appreciate everybody commonly discussing this and I respect all the
opinions.
All right.
Wife has nuts.
Bill,
longtime listener of the podcast.
Do,
can you shed a light on why my wife is unable to have a real conversation about
anything tangible politics,
current events,
music,
sports,
et Cetera.
Uh,
I swear she has no interest outside of her work and trashy TV,
teen mom,
TLC shows,
et cetera.
It's kind of sad.
She used to be so interesting,
but now that she's a mom,
she's a boar.
Well,
she's tired,
man.
Life is just not fun to her.
I love being a father,
but I just sense she can't handle the life side of her life.
What gives?
She's a fantastic mother to a son,
but his mailing it in as a wife.
MMM.
All right.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I've run into these kinds of problems.
All right.
Um,
you know,
shit changes obviously when you have a kid,
but with a woman,
like,
I don't even know what the fuck's going on.
They have like thunder and lightning going on in between their fucking ears,
like all hormones and all this crap and they get a c section.
They got to recover from a major abdominal surgery.
They go through a lot of stuff.
Plus,
you know,
their body literally changes.
They put on weight and shit and it's like so easy to fall into a depression,
get overwhelmed and all of that type of shit.
So I would say
mmm,
you know,
you're doing the guy thing where you just bare bones talking about it going,
she unable to have a real conversation about anything tangible.
I can tell you why my wife watches trashy TV.
She sometimes just doesn't want to think.
Okay.
And you know the level of worry that they have,
you know about what's going to happen.
The Kid,
am I doing a good job and all that type of shit.
What you need to do.
You need to have a date night,
once a week,
once every two weeks,
get a sitter and go out and kind of get that going again.
All right.
And uh,
I think your wife will enjoy it.
You guys will enjoy each other's company.
You got to have,
you know,
most of your life is going to be about the kid,
but you got to have that one little thing,
right.
That's what I would do.
And all the shit that you said to me,
I would not say to her.
So,
um,
anyways,
that is the,
uh,
that is a park.
Oh,
did anybody see when the,
uh,
the Bruins played the Calgary flames at home and they had the reunion of the,
1977 78 Boston Bruins set set a record even though they lost back to back years.
What's the Canadians or the finals?
Fucking heartbreaking losses.
But um,
that team had like the most 20 or more goals scores on it and all of these guys
I hadn't seen in a wreck right when I started watching hockey.
Uh,
these guys were what the Bruins?
It was Wayne Cashman.
Terry O'reilly,
Stan,
Jonathan,
uh,
Peter McNabb.
Uh,
okay.
Deborah Jean metallic genre tell he was gone by the time I started watching John
went sick was gone.
But I'll be just talking about the 20 goal scores.
Yeah.
Rick Middleton,
he was one of my favorites.
Um,
they did this great thing where they had a,
they just brought him back and they've shown all the highlights and they had don
cherry come out.
He was the coach at the time.
And um,
I,
it was so fucking great to see those guys.
And he did all these interviews and laugh and they're all fucking young hockey
plays of the shit that was just for the most part,
just humble and that type of thing.
And they will laugh and I'm like,
stand your honor.
The Hey,
you are known as a tough customer.
It's like one of the toughest fucking guys that ever played.
And he's like,
Hey,
I had a couple of scraps of whatever,
just yeah,
whatever.
It doesn't need to prove anything.
And um,
I actually only watched the first period and we played horrible defense in that
game.
I hope we fucking ended up winning that.
But,
uh,
I'm trying to hang in there with the Bruins and the Celtics.
I know I haven't been talking about as much this year,
but,
uh,
my kid became mobile,
so I spend most of my life running around after her and uh,
when she goes to sleep,
I sleep.
You know what I mean?
It's like that ludicrous song,
right when you move,
when I move you move.
I'd see other way when she sleeps,
you sleep just like that.
Will you see whatever the fucking song is?
That's what I always sing when I put her down.
While you sleep,
I sleep just like dad.
She goes,
he,
he and she fucking laughs at falls asleep and then I shut my eyes,
which feels like five seconds.
Then I have to wake back up again,
which is probably why I fell asleep during the phenomenal black pant that go
out,
check it out.
Uh,
really enjoyed that movie.
Even though I fell asleep and thought I was in a helicopter crash.
All right.
That's it in my apology to figure skaters.
You know what I mean?
Why do you have to be skating around all fucking emaciated?
You don't say?
I think it's about time.
They got some thickies out there.
All right.
God knows maybe they can do some new tricks.
Okay.
That's it.
That's the podcast.
Uh,
I'm off to New York and I'm going to do that benefit.
Looking forward to seeing a Bobby Kelly Rich Vos,
Joda,
Rosa,
all the people out there.
Uh,
shout out to Colin Quinn.
I know he's doing better and all that stuff.
Uh,
he's bent on just about every,
um,
Patrice O'Neal benefit,
uh,
salted the Earth Guy.
So,
uh,
giving him a shout out,
so hopefully he'll be up and around.
I can run into him in New York and try and break his balls.
All right,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves off checking team.
Check in with you on Thursday.
Jesus.